wood burning stoves have exploded in
popularity sales are up by two-thirds in
the last year alone
partly that's driven by Trends in
interior design but also increasingly as
a practical response to the soaring cost
of energy Ian Murr runs his business
from home and this winter has found
himself using his burner more than usual
we've turned our heating down quite low
and then we tried to stay in just you
know the kind of rooms with the wood
burner where the heat comes out from
there as the price of gas and energy has
just soared then we've definitely become
quite reliant on it I'll probably try
and work in this room so and just keep
it a little bit warmer and yeah we
really try and keep those energy bills
down
the low costs may be attractive but
domestic wood burning comes with costs
of a different kind it produces more of
a dangerous source of air pollution
called PM 2.5 than all the cars on the
road
breathing PM 2.5 is responsible for
somewhere around 20 to 30 000 extra
deaths in the UK each year when it comes
to wood burning we think that around 17
of the PM 2.5 that is being produced in
the UK is coming from people burning
wood the best way to see the health
impact of air pollution is to look at
those places where they've taken wood
burning away there's less wheeze in the
children in those communities there's
less people attending hospital for heart
respiratory problems
new research commissioned by global
action plan as part of a new awareness
campaign suggests few people know just
High polluting burning wood can be
and even when they do have some
awareness the impact was typically seen
to be small compared to things like
traffic and heavy industry the research
also find that most people using burners
do so for aesthetic purposes with only a
relatively small proportion using it as
their main source of heating
and it find that people who use burners
often show skepticism about the impact
of their stoves we're launching this
campaign to help provide information to
people who already have a wood burner
the information isn't out there at the
moment there isn't a public conversation
about the health impacts of wood burning
so I think people need to know this
this is my son's bedroom
and every evening and morning he does
his preventer inhaler but whilst
changing Minds could take time those
particularly sensitive to air pollution
like Ruth's heavily asthmatic Sun are
living with the consequences here and
now I can frequently smell wood smoke in
his bedroom and I've plugged up there's
an old kind of Edwardian
air vent that my son was a bit Wheezy
not too badly but I put him to bed in a
room that smelled of smoke and I just
thought how wrong it was that you know
not only is he breathing it in outside
but now you know we're at home in what's
supposed to be kind of a safe
environment and there is absolutely
nothing I can do
the government said it has already acted
to regulate wood burners and to ban more
polluting fuels the stove industry
Alliance said modern designs produce
significantly less PM 2.5 than open
fires and are a cost-effective way to
heat a home
for some wood burning is a necessity for
others it is a choice
by making the dangers of that choice
plain campaigners hope that public
enthusiasm for this achingly trendy
accessory slowly Burns itself out
Matthew Thompson Sky News